[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi-hi QuakeCon
love QuakeCon Wow
oh my god I am Ann Lewis I'm a Content
Manager at Bethesda and if you don't
already know this is the fallout 76
panel I just want to say if we seem a
little bit manic it's because like a lot
of you we are running on no sleep and an
unholy amount of energy drinks so good
though it's good it's gonna be great
it's gonna be awesome
joining me in hosting this panel it's my
very good friend I am Jessica Finster
senior community manager for all
Bethesda Game Studios titles we're
excited to be here with members of
Bethesda Game Studios they will be
joining us right about now so I'm gonna
introduce them so before we start with
our questions let's bring out Project
Lead Jeff gardener host studio director
mark tardes
your development director Chris Meyer &
Co studio director Tom Mustaine welcome
guys we are so so excited to be here
with you thank and with all of great con
obviously and our people watching on the
stream before we really dig in I want to
talk about something that feels like it
happened about a million years ago and
that is III we had some pretty big
announces from you guys last month at e3
including nuclear winter a brand new
competitive mode for Fallout 76 that is
currently in early beta let's roll the
trailer that we showed off at e3 and
feel free to sing along cuz I know we've
been doing that for months
your first test was making it to the
vault now your real trial begins
currently there is no overseer of vault
51 perhaps you will be the one
we are in serious need of leadership so
I have devised a unique process of
elimination goes battle to the death is
the only sure way to judge the superior
candidate this should prove interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there could only be one overseer good
luck
[Music]
it's a fun trailer it's a great trailer
it's a real quick it's taken me two
months to get that this is the first
time I've actually seen that trailer
since e3 so big props to the guys back
to your head again for another year
nuclear winter is available to all fall
at 76 players right now but for those
who haven't played it yet what exactly
is nuclear winter oh yeah so folks
haven't played yeah nuclear winter is a
battle royale inside the Fallout
universe so it's the first of its kind
inside the Fallout genre if you will so
what we have is you start inside well 51
which is an experimental vault and you
start with 52 other players which is
pretty cool there's actually a whole lot
of story inside that vault uncover and
you can run around and check out all the
cool stuff we've hidden inside there and
then you go out into the wasteland and
you basically collect all your loot you
start with nothing you have to collect
all your loot and try and survive and so
you're looking for nuclear codes and
trying to find good weapons I mean while
avoiding AI they're out to get you and
other players and you're on a team with
four other or three other people and it
gets pretty intense we've had some
pretty pretty nuts things happen to us
since we've been playing this we've got
a bunch of stories for that but yeah it
is a blast to play now the nukes
I like nukes nukes for fun I did I did
one last I played last week by myself I
was running around and I launched a new
when one of our streams we tried we
tried to launch a nuke we do streams
pretty frequently and totally try to
launch a nuke missed everybody but I did
one the other day and got seven people
with the nuke I'm done okay things about
our streams whenever I be playing and I
don't see you on the stream but I hear
briefcase
and if you want a briefcase in the booth
over here we have the nuke briefcases
you actually pick them up get a picture
with them so you can't keep them no
collected I are encouraging you to take
don't take them yeah try you guys should
definitely tune into those streams so at
the office my offices shares a wall with
Tom and Tom volunteer to do these
streams and so I'm sitting there just
trying to do work and it's like the wall
slam and I'll hear noises I heard you
buy your keyboard I don't bite my
keyboard initially you mentioned III
initially a nuclear winter was added as
a free trial week during this or added
during the free trial week for e3 but
then he decided to keep it running why
did you guys decide to do that short
answer fear of you guys let me explain
that so leading up to the show we had
been working on it for a while we knew
it was it was fun just through the play
test that we were doing at work we like
we knew the game was a lot of fun and we
knew it was it was pretty solid and
pretty stable but we wanted to use they
e3 week as kind of a just a test because
like around the office we don't get
enough people to really stress and
really get the amount of feedback that
you guys can help provide to us so we
want to do a sneak peek for that for
that week and just like take all the
feedback in and then take it down
analyze everything take our time make it
all like do everything we wanted to do
and then re-release it down the road a
little ways and so we that's the plan we
went into and then like a couple days
into e3 like I think it was the four of
us we were back in the interview booths
and we're all high-fiving because was
going so well and the feedback was so
good and then I think it was like I
think Todd Howard and Pete Hines walked
in and they're like you guys know you
can't take that down
if you took that down there would be a
riot so we have to change our plans like
let's leave it up and instead of taking
it down in working on it we'll just work
on it as a live product and keep
following what your guys's feedback is
online I knew it was good when my wife
texted me I'm the overseer [ __ ] so I
will be the first to admit and just
might be the second I am not the
strongest nuclear winter player and
that's putting it gently do you have any
advice for me and people like me so my
general advice is uh just shoot others
and don't get shot but that's the that
was where I was failing that's one of my
favorite parts about this so Appalachia
and and 76 is really dense like there's
there's trees there's cover there's lots
and lots of detail and so when you
really want to hide and try and not get
caught because I'll pop it in and I'm
like I'm fine everything's fine and
bunch of people spawn around me and I I
tend to like come in with a couple
people and there's always four and so
I'll just sit there and chill and wait
for people you hear all the fighting and
these go over and like take stuff out
see how that actually works relatively
well in the battle well it's kind of a
hide-and-seek game right and then when
we play with Jessica for example we
basically say okay you run that way get
their attention
and then we'll shoot them when they
start shooting at you it's my mo for
like first for some shooters that I'm
not good at Battle Royale just run and
then everybody get in the other flank
and I'll die in two seconds but it was
worth it for the team
communication is key in this you talk to
your other people and say go do that and
we'll do this and cover you in we found
something cool so yeah it's there's a
lot of a lot of that but it's it's a
it's fun to do yeah are you looking at
me
you get others oh man yeah you got to be
better off asking me for haircare advice
nuclear winter my best advice is to team
up with people better than you
that's that's usually my key to success
either that or learned how to blend into
shrubbery yeah
I heard there's something going around
the office rebuilding a lot of outhouses
yeah so you can build camps in nuclear
winter as well and you can bring
blueprints over from 76 so if you build
like a crazy campus 76 you can make a
blueprint from it and bring in a nuclear
winter and so we have yeah I think we
have a couple people that that are
really good at hiding in outhouses so
they build a little forest of outhouses
so you're running around you're feeling
good and you come in suddenly there's
like a twenty six outhouses you waiting
for the Dordogne one goes it's like
there's pretty other shooting yuning
yeah whatever one of our testers Cassady
she loves doing that and you can walk up
this is a Cassidy forest I'm going this
way now the first time that happens to
me someone jumped out naked with a
shotgun yeah there's gonna be a piece of
loot in there can we get any sort of
hint as to what's on the horizon for
nuclear winter what's next no no yes so
the number one request that you guys
have asked for is a change of location
so we've been working hard at doing just
that so very soon we'll be taking the
battle to the town of Morgantown and
we'll be saying
what we wanted to do was find something
completely different than flatwoods and
morgantown offers us that it's a lot
more urban there's a lot more
verticality to it and so it'll be it'll
be a whole new whole new way for you
guys to to battle each other and a new
map to master yeah the the Morgantown
area that we cover here has the highest
point inside Appalachia so it's the
tallest tallest spot on the map you've
got the Morgantown Airport you've got
vaulteq you there's all kinds of great
areas in there and then as we've moved
the area the location of the storm has
moved across Appalachia we actually come
across new monsters - so we're gonna be
running into the Grafton monster there
which might be showing here in a moment
but this there's a huge area of water
mass like there's a big lake in so if
you want to spawn in the lake and get
your your ads you'll mutate into
something cool which a nuclear winter
again you get rad mutations and they're
actually always positive we hide all the
negative effects so you could turn in
something cool at the cost of your your
other side of your health but yeah it's
it is a really fun location much more
urban sprawl rooftops jumping around and
we've been we've been playing it right
now and people are really digging it so
I should be coming very soon so there is
a lot more coming for nuclear winter but
you guys definitely haven't forgotten
about adventure mode in fact a little
while ago you announced that volt raids
would be coming to the game how will
these what yes thank you somebody's very
excited how will these work and when can
players expect this content Chris sure
so we we are finalizing the first vault
which is vault 94 it is a pretty
expansive vault we do think it would
very challenging I myself have have been
challenged into plates as many times
trying to get to the end of it I think
some of the rewards are really cool that
you're gonna get out of it some of them
might actually help you hide a little
better in the environment yeah
you see one on the screenshots coming up
here soon when is it coming out it
should be in the next few weeks I do
believe we are hitting the final link uh
ch's on it
barring something really major
unforeseen we'll get it out soon and
definitely August
how many players are these vaults made
for the vaults are designed for four
players
you can't solo duo triple them if you as
you will if you're a masochist and
they're super hard so just in a little
more context there when you go and you
get to choose one of three different
difficulty levels the first one I
believe is called novice and you go in
it's still very difficult to get me
wrong it's probably a good way to get
used to the vault and the puzzles and
how to handle it it's very puzzle based
you have to figure out you know the
right blend and balance between taking
down mobs and doing in opening doors and
doing different things the second two
levels at a time pressure that rewards
go up so you there's internal time
pressures minutes minute but this is a
meta time pressure so you have to do the
whole thing in a certain amount of time
remember we're inside the vault it's a
great place to we're legendary spawn so
you're both the farm legendaries in
there you'll get mid rewards halfway
through and at the end so if you fail at
the end you're not totally unrewarded
obviously you also get all the loot you
gather in there and at the end we're
rewarding different pieces of armor and
we're gonna put a new set piece armor
and you'll see it right there it's the
power armor with all the ferns on it I
call it the potted plant power armor but
it is super useful nuclear winter it's a
fun exciting thing and once you have the
whole set it gives you an additional
bonus so there's a new mechanic rating
to the game we're put set bonuses in the
game and you're gonna be able to loot
them out of the vault raids you might be
able to solo that content there's no way
I can work somebody that works what a
whole play test I think they figured it
out it is hard I think my favorite
personal part about vault raids is that
anybody that's thinking about like
storming area 51 this could practice and
not do that virtual storming and
collecting goodies so so you mentioned
that vault 94 is coming first can we
talk about any of the other vaults any
differences in themes or challenges we
are actively in development of a second
vault I'll be honest it will be we don't
know when it's going to come out exactly
but it will be in the not-too-distant
future and if it depends on the
community right if you like these and
you and we and you want us to build more
we'll keep holding and we love them
internally
we open do we we do want to space out
the release enough to where we can
gather some feedback about 94 and then
act on it with with vault 96 and of
course when we talk about big changes
coming to adventure mode we can't forget
about wastelanders which was announced
at e3 this year another so if you
haven't seen it or if you just want to
watch it again because it's fun let's
take a watch at the teaser trailer we
revealed at e3 this year it's been some
time since thought 76 opened its door
and we all discovered that Appalachia
isn't quite what it used to be I don't
think any of us expected
from people
to actually come back are you from that
vote can you help us
we've traveled pretty far heard there's
hope here in Appalachia folk rebuilding
fighting back we'll fight to right by
your side
[Music]
we've been everywhere and seen
everything and the one thing we've
learned is this you've got to claim the
wasteland before it claims
question is are you with us
I love watching people get excited about
dialogue tree I know a lot of players
are as excited about wastelanders as I
am and as an is it Jack what can you
tell us about this new completely free
update
it's got NPCs no I'm actually getting
PTSD from being at the shrine theater
and having to go on stage and talk about
you gotta start it that's right that's
right
so anyways wastelanders is it's again
year one was the vault so many six
players coming out establishing
economies which you've successfully done
sometimes to our chagrin you've done put
you know but basically re-establishing
human presence in the wasteland and now
I guess despite the fact that you could
fly there every day people want to come
back so we're getting you know obviously
settlers and Raiders faction are coming
back into the into the wild Appalachia
there's going to be new settlements we
are this is they're going to fully
infest the map I just need to be clear
like that we're gonna put new random
encounters points of interests there's
actually sub factions not just those two
that will be involved here they'll
obviously be dialogue with all those a
whole new quest time we want to make
sure this constants also sustainable you
just can't just do a main quest and be
done with it
so you're gonna be seeing this presence
in the game going forward now this this
is constant we're going to lean on we
think for the for as long as the game is
around right I think the number one
requested feature after launch was where
are the NPCs we want we want to see
humans so they're here took a while to
to write all that story I can having say
played some of the early play tests it
does dramatically change us the feel of
the game from the moment you walk out of
the ball and you're interacting with
NPCs to going to a tavern where there's
an NPC bartender I think it changes a
lot for me I do think we will be leaning
into this you know going forward
with more story even as people complete
this it kind of leads us into the next
question I mean this is such a huge
change to the game how do you predict
that the overall player experience is
going to evolve with wastelanders I
think a lot of its going to be feel I
think the world is going to feel more
alive it's going to be more variety of
encounters it's just it's going to be a
more varied world not just with the
story with with people finding the
raiders finding the settlers but also
all the random encounters the the
hostile Raiders that you run into some
of the the the minor factions that we're
not going to talk about yet things like
that are going to dramatically change
the game yeah one of the minor factions
is going to be robbed on a cultist of
the Mothman so while there are minor
facts remember that the Raiders aren't
just like you know crazy cannibals
there's those kind of Raiders but the
Raiders in the settlement are more you
know they used extreme measures to
protect themselves right the settlers we
try to dance with in shades of gray not
just black and white so the settlers
have their own motivations as well so
might need to be nefarious you will
uncover those throughout their quests
and remember as as I'm sure as you folks
all play games and I do like there's a
story I'm telling myself in the story
the game's telling me so this is the
element of the game that that we wanted
to add back in the story the game's
telling you and that's there with the
overseer a quest line and other things
within the game but this is really like
you interacting with these NPCs their
motivations their hopes their fears and
influencing them right through that
through dialogue and your actions so
with you know within the dialogue trees
you will be able to go through them in
using your specials you'll be able to
influence how those dialogues play out
depending on your actions we are putting
a reputation system in so you'll be able
to align yourselves with one fashion the
other or play the middleman and play
both maybe double-cross against each
other you'll be able to in once in in
fairness you're not going to ever be
locked into one or the other you will be
able to you won't be making permanent
decisions so we're just super excited
the more and more about wastelanders do
here we we were starting to see all the
little POS and the tiny little stories
that come from these so you can come
across to Raiders trying to kill a
Brahman
you decide to help those Raiders do you
decide to save the Brahman do you say to
help the Raiders save the Brahman then
kill them all it's all it to you we
already talked about how excited we are
for the dialogue trees but I think a lot
of people are really curious with a game
like this how did the dialogue trees
work compared to past titles and also
how will they work with followed 76 as
per crud system they so I think as Jeff
mentioned the attributes you put in your
specials will give you more choices or
different choices on the dialogue trees
so a character with more perception
might have some different options versus
another character if he was more respect
for charisma or for strength even so
that that's how we expect it to play so
it should be different depending upon
how how the special points are allocated
across your character and I can't
remember your other question so are
Europe sorry stream no so we remember
like it's not just it's also based on
your actions so you'll have dialogue
choices available to you whether or not
your reputation within that faction is
is good or bad or neutral so the
combination of those and also remember
this isn't the fallout for dialogue
system this is more like fallout 3 we
have a list of stuff so we have a list
of things and you'll be able to you know
it's not you're not just limited to
those those sort of generic options in
order the designers have to force the
dialogue options for things that made no
sense so you know we're like I said and
the combination of the reputation system
the new dialogue trees I mean this isn't
gonna be a full-fledged RPG we're super
excited and again this is just the
beginning of that we are good these are
the tools we're building to create all
future content as well and with the
introduction of NPCs and the factions
and settlements will we also see the
return of companions yes so
[Laughter]
the there will be companions we're still
iterating exactly on the mechanics of
how they're going to work but there will
be companions that you can bring back to
your camp and then they will take you on
various quests and you can you know do
things with them that are very
specialized companions the key point is
is that mainly they're going to stay in
your camps the one right you know
they're gonna be in your camp I'm very
specific quests they will definitely
accompany you to help you or hinder you
or surprise you with certain things on
your way but remember that in and you
can definitely romance these companions
and go up and down favorite them
depending on again your actions within
the game and what where they're aligned
I know tumblr was very curious about the
romance possibilities so that's good I
like romancing things in video games can
we talk about anything else it's going
to be coming with the wastelanders
update including some of the new weapons
that we saw on the concept art that we
shared or some of the new enemies like
that creepy guy from the trailer
anything or new locations like crater
which we saw in the teaser I'm excited
about the the I can't can I even say
what the guy is walking on the power
armor are it's you actually some more
concept art of weapons that we're doing
we're doing a whole new Gauss tree like
a weapon spread of weapons that guy is
the Wendigo Colossus so he does have a
name and he did a creepiest thing I
think we put the game we put some [ __ ]
in that game more plasma weapons
these are floaters they're from if
anyone remembers the original games
they're from the original fallouts yeah
more sorry I guess it's sort of weird
we're supposed to be talking over that's
not reading from this is again more
ghost weapons more mini guns the
Colossus again we're also putting
obviously you saw in the trailer archery
and bows and while that might seem a
step back from submachine guns and nukes
you can shoot we're gonna put new perks
behind that and so you're going to be
able to you
if you're more stealthy character or
hunter we're also gonna allow you to
maybe strap dynamite arrows and shoot
them which I love because I grew up with
Dukes of Hazzard and sure a lot of
people are interested to know do you
have like a time frame or a window that
we can share about when we can expect to
play wastelanders people take this stuff
very I know we are shooting like I said
for fall we are targeting November ok
can I just say how envious I am of all
of you guys that you're going to be able
to experience this thing as a confronted
product fresh this fall because that's
like one of the one of the few negatives
as being of being a developer at BGSU
like you see it as it's being created
and you don't see like the final picture
and I think as a fan be able to just
experience it as they like this is it
that's that's awesome and I wish I could
do it
fallout 76 is constantly evolving and
adapting to player feedback which is I
mean honestly awesome because it's meant
a lot of change a lot of feedback a lot
of good bad what are some of the things
that you guys will be focusing just in
the months leading up to wastelanders so
one of the things will be is my mic on
I can't here we go there we go one of
the things we are looking at doing in
the very very near future making some
changes to the event system a lot of
this does come with player feedback like
we're going to make fast travel to
events free we are going to make the
events that are active on the map very
visible in the UI we're doing things
like making sure that if you participate
in the event you have a chance to get a
reward as well as making their rewards
more predictable so I think it's a lot
of changes around events that the
players will like and it's based
directly on feedback that we've
collected with yeah we realized if I'm
sorry one of the cornerstones of our
game obviously the community and the
community systems we're talking about
wastelanders nuclear winter but we are
very big on continuing to support
community-based events and including
including this and so you'll you know
you'll pull up your mini-map you'll be
able to see how long the events been
going
what the rewards are fast travel there
for free we're also going to separate
public events from regular events to
better get people together playing those
make them a little harder a little more
rewarding and we'll like Chris said more
predictable any upcoming quality of life
improvements okay I've got one for work
so we're adding a 1 to nuclear winter
that people have requested quite a bit
it's a we're calling a perk choosing
what it does is when you get a new perk
card and it's a duplicate we're giving
you tickets you can redeem to basically
purchase perks with those tickets you
get for selecting your own perks so
right now perks are basically kind of
randomized inside nuclear winter but
with perk choosing you get to craft your
own deck based on the dupes you get so
that was a big request and that's going
in relatively soon so people can get to
a frog-leg sooner or anything else that
they want sooner so that's one that
we're putting in from a quality life
perspective on the nuclear winter side
Thank You frogs although we did nerf
frog legs people ask that too
diminishing returns it comes all good
you know also we are for wastelanders we
have two more big ambitious on goals
that will land at or around the launch
of wastelanders one is our we're calling
it internally it's a sort of a pointy
hat word renormalization where we're
basically looking at the balance as a
whole and trying to make sure that it's
not any new players coming in don't see
a big wave of level 300 players and feel
like they can't have fun and compete in
the game so we're gonna look at making
that a little more
look it's called normalize where you
take the highs and the lows and you sort
of bring them together a little bit
obviously strong characters will still
be strong and weak characters will still
have things they struggle with but we're
gonna try to bring that in a little
especially for events and things so
players can engage and come together and
help each other and support which this
community loves to do secondly we've
talked about this as well the legendary
perk system so I'll give you a little
couple I'm probably spoiling some
advanced questions there looking ahead
on the legendary perk system like we're
being sort of AG on this because it's
still we it's still being developed when
you're in game design you have to
iterate on things and you put them in
the game and you have to try things and
see what works and what doesn't work and
before you guys get to try things
and see what works and didn't work so
people should have laughed at that
anyway so anyway what we're trying to do
is basically after level 50 around every
50 levels you guys are gonna hold me to
this it's probably gonna change you're
gonna get out you're gonna be able to
choose a special that you get become
legendary in and then within that
special you're gonna have a ray of poor
cards you can choose from just for that
slot that you're then able to level up
as well so it you as you and if you're
already level 300 you'll get several of
these right off the bat and so you'll be
able to get yeah it's cool you're
building a new perks super-powerful
perks frankly and you'll be able to then
slot them in and use them on your
character even cooler we're adding sort
of a new game+ in will you'll be able to
go back when you start a new character
you'll be able to then use those perks
on the new character as well so you'll
have a leg up in case you want to start
a new character so yeah we're super
thrilled about both those changes I
think that so you're getting with again
waste liners which is totally free
you're gonna get all this as well so in
our remaining time we do have a few
community questions that we pulled from
a our forums last week so just you
mentioned how important community
feedback is in reference to getting that
feedback and reporting where's the dev
team looking and what is the best place
for players to submit feedback if they
don't already know we look at a lot of
different I cannot move we we look at a
lot of different places but the two
primary ones are our own forums and read
it those are the places that not only
our developers frequently go to to look
our community team really surfaces
things from there to our live team daily
so we are getting daily reports on
what's being talked about what's
trending what's what's important to the
community so we take all that feedback
and then we you know obviously the
things that we can fix quickly we try to
do in a patch and the things that we
can't fix quickly like at NPCs of the
game
than weave that's more scheduled out
long-term we really encourage all of you
guys to be active in the various forums
or on reddit or whatever and that's
something we truly pay attention to in
fact we even reached out to a handful of
you earlier this year before a nuclear
winter went live and brought you down
here at the Dallas to hang out with us
and play nuclear winter in advance just
to kind of get a get a pulse of what you
guys would would would think of the game
before we went to e3 with it and that's
the kind of stuff that we continue to
plan on doing going forward so be active
yep I think another big question that
we've seen is pts list of things we
can't do really quickly Chris tell me
what a pts is for the audience we are we
are we are public tests we are actively
engaging in several measures to make
sure that the builds and that are
delivered to you are at the highest
quality so obviously that is one of them
there there are others as well it's just
again we have to we have to balance what
we we want to ship wastelanders and all
the stuff I just talked about too so but
obviously we also want that to be as
high of quality as possible so we're
actively engaging in and making sure
that these builds get to you either
earlier through a pts over something
else can players expect any balance
changes for weapons and armor coming
down the line for a nuclear winter yes
it's something we've continued to do I
think every update we've we've done some
level of bouncing either to perks or to
weapons we'll continue to do it as
something feels over powerful will will
adjust if we see something not being
used enough will boost it yeah we'll do
it as Jeff mentioned for wastelanders
we're looking at doing a pretty big
balance pass on the entire game and we
always look for high nails things that
are either being are underpowered or
overpowered and we try not to our new
philosophy is to if we have to nerf
anything we try to also raise things as
well so you're getting we're giving you
options and different play styles I like
asynchronous design so I like different
trade-offs not just an undamaged output
but so we always look for ways to make
things have different advantages
and clear decisions for you guys to make
guys and girls to make is you play the
game are there any plans to increase the
camp budget we are looking at ways to
increase the camp budget yes we
recognize it I mean building isn't a
very important part of the game
especially the elder game it's it's
something that we see players who have
played for a long time engaged with very
frequently we see that both in direct
community feedback and also in our our
own data on the back end there is a
trade-off to just increasing the entire
budget so we're looking at creative ways
to to give players more opportunities to
build and in different places in the
world maybe you know also with things
like private servers and stuff like that
you know coming in the near future
[Applause]
keeping ahead to that question what was
that
any news on private servers oh yes
they're coming sooner than you think
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
will there ever be server wide event
notifications I sorry I could not serve
a wide event notifications server well
that's what we talked about well yeah oh
yeah we sort of we sort of covered that
with it with the map changes we're gonna
do so when you're looking for events
you'll see them clearly and you can go
there for free and know where they're at
and you'll make better decisions on what
a bunch want to join they're not joint
and I have one more question left flash
knocked was fun are there any more
events coming soon yeah there we are
working on some seasonal events we're
working on one for Halloween we'll be
working on some for early winter and we
love Fasnacht too so we can't wait to
bring it back as well and remember next
week is meat week so if you haven't read
about that online the super mutant gram
is going to be offering more more
seasonal based events on collecting
meats it'll be it'll be a ton of fun and
I'm sure the community will get a lot
out of it that should be coming in our
next patch
oh sorry eleven point next Thursday
eight one is our goal before we close
out the panel we want to talk about
something that is very important to us
at Bethesda this year we have partnered
with one up on cancer for an ongoing
nuclear winter fundraising event that
will run through the end of quakecon so
go play I think last time I checked in
we we were they were just about to break
$5,000 so let's see how much better we
can do we got another full day or so of
you guys playing so go check it out go
talk to our team everybody that's
Manning that booth is one of one of our
one of the employees at be GSI go talk
to them go play go win some money the
conditions in which we donate I think
you know the details I have this detail
to make sure I read it to get it correct
but that's all donates seventy six
dollars to one up on cancer up to ten
thousand dollars if you come in the top
ten of a match you guys can do that you
guys everybody here can definitely do
that
and of course you can make your own
charitable donations as well yeah to pop
by the booth yeah wait spits blast you
get into the top ten and boom we changed
the number on the board did this do some
math and see how much we've raised it's
it feels really good so definitely check
it out
and that brings us to the end of the
panel as you guys heard today between
fall trades and nuclear winter and
wastelanders there is a lot on the
horizon for Fallout 76 but we have to
get the hell off the stage so the doom
can take over yeah you guys are waiting
for doom right answer your question yes
and thank you guys for watching and do
the home that couldn't go in here thank
you and don't forget you can check out
our weekly fallout streams every
Wednesday as well where Tom may or may
not be joining me thank you thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
set me up for fun with my wife's like
I know it's good
like its left side the side girl you
know
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and l2
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
how you guys do it welcome quick on i'm
jason levy senior community manager of
doom eternal hey i'm matt Grandstaff i'm
the director of community at bethesda
we're gonna jump right into doom eternal
so let's welcome our guests from its
software creative director hugo martin
and executive producer marty Stratton
thank you hey you guys doing very good
we love you
so we want to just jump into the game
but Hugo huger actually played the game
which is gonna be awesome but you want
to tell but like everybody what we're
gonna be seeing here if you haven't been
playing the demo downstairs what are we
doing well prepare yourselves might be
playing on a controller yeah I'm sorry
okay to get him to play with you yeah
and we're gonna be playing the demo that
everybody's playing out there yeah if
you haven't played it this will be a
good a good insight and if you're
watching there are people watching right
yep okay so everyone watching online
everyone watching online you know you
get to see you get to seek the creative
director play the game we're gonna talk
through it and and give you some
insights into why we do certain things
and and why the game is some so damn fun
awesome yeah and the great stick around
to the end of course as well because the
Slayers Club a lot of you guys probably
are members of the Slayers Club but
we've been taking your questions all
week long yeah so we're gonna be
grilling you guys with a couple cool
questions as well but underground really
want this to be kind of a live tutorial
get to share every project has what we
call a design story which is basically
the story of the development of the game
the decisions that are made and we'd
like the opportunity to share some of
that with you and kind of educate you on
and some of the thought behind some of
the decisions we made some of the
reasons why we're doing certain things
so this isn't going to necessarily be a
watch this I'm gonna eviscerate the the
demons in like a speedrun I'm feel like
I'm setting up excuses for myself
there's a little bit of that inequity
but but ya know it's a great opportunity
for us we really appreciate you guys
coming cool it's also I mean it's also
we're saying right before he jumps in
you know I mean we're still in
development were so a few months away
from from launch and this is even you
know in a development timeline
perspective we we really started working
on this specific demo like back in April
or so leading up to e3 because we first
we first took this to e3 so Lots has
changed since then we'll even point out
some of that stuff you know we'll talk
about talk about how things have evolved
even since since this demo was create
it's very very representative but yeah
but we're still mid development so cool
let's run over there they need to see it
on the screens everyday there we go
everybody impressed so right here you
know again we'll pull back the curtain
for you you are the player you play as
the doom Slayer our goal is always to
make you feel powerful because the
character of the Slayer is powerful that
is our power fantasy that's why you buy
doom and there's nothing you know you
know everybody reacts when Hugo walks to
the yeah you know certainly walking into
a room and having this kind of effect on
a group of people is definitely a power
fantasy you know like and it makes the
player feel strong so while it's funny
and awesome it's definitely meant to
make you feel stronger and that's that's
why you buy the game is it's a power
fantasy and he's taking the keycard he
is taking the gun but he's not being you
know forceful or attacking yeah but he
takes what he wants yeah exactly
there's a little bit of like walking
into the DMV and doing this that would
be awesome yeah
that's where these ideas come from you
want to talk about that weapon at all
that we're seeing there
it's the BFG 10,000 yes because you know
9,000 wasn't enough no it's over 9,000
yeah and you that so actually it's it's
we're saying this this demo all of this
takes place in one level of the game and
and we're jumping through like that
level every time we go through a portal
that's actually kind of jumping you
ahead in the story or in jumping you
ahead in the experience but this I mean
this level is massive I mean you see
here we're on a Phobos moon base and and
you're fighting under the BFG and then
you end up much further in the level
here in a second it's I mean it's it's a
really epic experience the levels are
much larger than than what they weren't
doing 2016 really kind of pulls you in
and even each level almost has a
three-act structure to it in a lot of in
a lot of cases and you get these really
awesome visual set pieces that are very
different even over the course of a
single level I think it's it's fair to
say we're internally right that the in
the first two levels of Doom eternal you
probably see more stuff and do more
things than you do in the entirety of
the last game you know in terms of those
set pieces that he talked about and and
it never stops honestly like the the
last three levels of the game alright so
what are you doing here
so I play on an inverted to control it
okay that's more support than I expected
where are my Goldeneye people because
that's how Goldeneye came when it set up
right there's some good Goldeneye chokes
last night in the end you guys just
helped me out so everybody at the office
heard that because I got more [ __ ] at
the office for his inverted sticks than
anything
so visually we love the plasma cuz it's
got this sweet pop but there's a utility
to using the plasma that if you come up
against anybody with a shield you can
actually pop their shield and it creates
an explosion so it's kind of a tactical
decision of when to use the plasma right
now I'm using it just to show it off
against the AI but certainly I would
save it in the game for shield guys and
in this this demo we didn't really have
that pop in there quite yet so it
definitely destroys the shield's really
fast but in the shipping game it's
actually going to create an explosion so
you you're gonna feel really smart for
using it which is pretty much our goal
with everything is we want you to feel
like you're in control and and and
making good decisions or at least asking
you to make how long have you been
waiting for that one you're handcrafted
I mean the 1ups are just a really fun
fun thing to search for in the game and
they work very much like ol Dark Age
1ups clearly you know we have
checkpoints and and when you die you
load at the checkpoint but when you die
with a one-up you can see it up there in
the top left of the screen that that
keeps track of how many how many 1ups
you have and and if you die with the one
up it it automatically takes one of
those away and and lets you kind of have
a little invulnerable period to kind of
get your bearings again and and you keep
you keep fighting without having to load
a checkpoint so when you get into those
really really tough arenas man you're
you're you're really happy to have a few
you know two or three 1ups up in the
corner but you earn those that's the
coolest part it's not a gimme from the
game we're not giving you a
get-out-of-jail-free card
you know for nothing you you search for
the secrets and your reward is you get
to continue into the fight without
having to reload a checkpoint so it
feels really satisfying it also enables
us as designers to really challenge you
like to ask a lot of you we want to make
doom a game that's worth your time to
master you know I don't think anybody
wants to buy for 60 bucks a game that's
just a cakewalk you know I need to make
your way through I mean some of the 1ups
are pretty hard to get to yeah they're
easy some of them are harder yep
anybody can make a hard game it's easy
to make a hard game just do like hitscan
enemies that like you know shoot you in
the head and spawn behind you we wanted
to make a game that that was like a
combat puzzle so the solution is to be
aggressive and and you see that when you
play the demo so it's more of like
something that's worth your time to
master to increase engagement levels for
you guys so you feel really engaged or
thinking it's not just hard for the sake
of part that actually goes into that ego
plays this and you know you kind of saw
it with the plasma how important the
feedback is we talked a lot about it
last year at QuakeCon with the
destructible demons and you know it
looks amazing I mean when you get things
like that where the guy just blows apart
but you know it all ties together with
that design story of engaging you and
making you feel smart having you make
decisions in Doom you make them really
really fast it's it's like it's like a
game of speed chess so the feedback
really needs to be precise and amazing
and you need to you need to really
understand what you're doing right there
Hugo's going for the weak spot you kind
of heard that ping and that's that's
shooting the turret off the top of the
Iraq nice rond a lot of the demons have
this and mang Kubis has one too I have
in the lower left hand corner I have a
blood punch charge and the blood punch
is like a super melee shot so I could
pepper him up with shots Birnam ah
so what's what's what's really fun is
first I want to disable that guy's guns
and every heavy or near every heavy has
a weak point of some kind that you can
exploit and you really want to do that
because they're designs you're gonna die
they're designed to tuned in such a way
that you really have to take out their
weak points because if you don't take
out the Iraq neutrons gun you're gonna
have a really hard time right there
where I said you know you're gonna die
it's a perfect example his health was
low
his only his best move there was to stay
and fight that manky looks like because
he knew if he glory killed that man q
buster killed him he was going to get
health that's that's kind of that you
know you have to be aggressive you have
to be aggressively managing your
resources glory kills in this case and
and kills give you health so he was down
he was he was really low but so was the
man cubist and you got that feedback
because he was just shredded like they
got almost all of his all of his skin
had been blown off and you know I hey
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna finish
this fight and I'm gonna get help and
you saw it there he went from 30 to 90
just for killing the man Cuba's in
Seville so you'll use the you know the
flame belch as well to get armor yeah
you kind of have to know like is this
the time to use the chainsaw because you
need to get more ammo or you know what
you also saw there and what we're most
proud of is with the AI I was trying to
you know I'm trying to talk and I was
trying to rush in to like deliver the
blood punch but he has kind of this area
deny of denial attack where he shoots
the ground with his cannons which pushes
the player away does a significant
amount of damage so basically we think
of him like an Abrams tank and you can't
just run up to neighbour his tank you
know like it wouldn't be an easy thing
to do so it's the the AI you know
keeping you in check and and making you
play the game thinking a little bit more
about the decisions you make like you
can't just run up to our tank and shoot
it with a double-barrel shotgun
point-blank he has a response to that
which will steer you into other weapons
like long-range weapons like the Gauss
or the rocket launcher that's that's why
we have that in there we don't want a
point-blank double-barrel shotgun
to be the answer to everything now if
you're a double-barrel shotgun you know
not like like pretty much everybody is
you can you can hit him with a strong
shot from the Gauss or the rocket
launcher and you'll notice he does like
a falter which is not quite a stagger
it's just an enemy reaction that's like
an you've created an opening then you
could meet hook to him and deliver that
double-barrel shotgun blast but the game
will not allow you to just walk up to
him take your time and shoot him which
which is what I was trying to do which
is why I almost died and we love that
stuff I mean that's it's a thinking
man's action game that's that's really
og's
you thought portal I like I get applause
for inversion I get applause for playing
bad I like this yes you saw there we do
it we have a lot of like you know our
spaces are much bigger there's there's
areas like this where you know you can
fall off the world we're not we're not
trying to overly punish the player that
like in that's how the game operates
right there you fall off if you fall off
the world and it just quick spawns you
right back up to this hot no no low time
there I didn't take one of his extra
lives so it keeps you honest but if it
doesn't you know piss you off too much
so it's allowed you to also go to new
places I mean the label design has
completely changed we're like you're not
just kind of going you know we can ask
more of the player because of the quick
spawn so art reversals and and our
traversal puzzles would get real
Annoying real fast if it was a load
checkpoint every time he died so it's
just a quick spawn right back to the
ledge so this guy spawning these shields
is one of my favorite AI carcass he's
the carcass so basically what he does is
he spawn shields to protect other AI
from you glory killing them and he'll
spawn him right in front of your face
when you're targeting them or you're
heading in for like a chainsaw or
something and when I use so this guns
more powerful than it was in the last
game by by a lot but it moves slower and
it does a lot more self damage so and it
has less ammo and none of this stuff is
new this is basically what was in Doom 1
we always look to do one for our
inspiration so if I run around with this
rocket launcher and this guy's around I
do that and basically really hurt myself
so he makes you kind of reconsider like
alright maybe I shouldn't be using the
rocket launcher let me switch to one of
these and he kind of just makes you
think that's everything
that's the funniest for my god
everything every gets you every every AI
is meant to make you think so again
he'll he'll make you reconsider using
that rocket launcher but then he spawns
the shield which you can disable with
your plasma so there's there's like a
lot of speed chess kind of decisions
that are going on the more you play the
game the more you understand the metas
the stronger you feel because you could
just start to you know really wreck the
AI but we're not just gonna hand you
that power fantasy without without your
earning it I mean you got it you got to
learn you got to learn all those metas
and and and the counters and what each
AI each AI does all right so let's top
this guy's here it's much better in the
game right now when you're properly
Billy that was with the plasma ring yes
the plasma will disable all enemy shield
so you saw you guys saw the zoom hunter
in yesterday's demo and he actually has
a shield that covers the top half of his
body so part of the minigame with him is
disabling that shield to allow you to
deliver damage to him there's actually
we kind of balanced this for you know as
we as we made this for e3 and and and
knew that we were gonna be bringing it
to quake on you know you're basically
making a demo for people who are kind of
starting like they've never played this
game before usually you get to take them
on a on a long journey of learning but
we didn't want to start people beginning
the game because you know you don't have
a lot of stuff so yah we yeah that's a
perfect example of what's carcass
pain in the ass but so we balance this
you'll you'll notice you know there's
there's some resources in the world but
but really most of what you're doing is
is managing your resources through glory
kills for change chainsawing enemies to
get to get the ammo and and and getting
armor through flame belch and and I'll
tell you it it's awesome when you when
you actually have the game in your hands
and
you're checking even way more so than
doom 2016 you really think about that
stuff and when you see you'll see how
colorful and and obvious the the pickups
are you you see the blue health files
they're very reminiscent of point of the
original games but even the health packs
and and it's because they're there the
resources are more scarce in the
environment I think they just like kills
that's this let me break things in half
so the same as last time
glory kills are contextual whatever limb
or direction you look at wherever you
put your cross how you get a different
glory kill which I love because again
once once you get better and better at
the game you feel like you're
choreographing your own martial arts I
don't yes so I was kind of saving him so
we have the we have the Cacodemons and
our animation team is like so happy yeah
like they are the nicest it's really
true oh you wouldn't believe it yeah
they come up with like when you when you
know them these are these are
church-going good people but they found
a way to take them doom blade and really
shove it into a brainstorming
discussions there holy I've so many
times I'm like we gotta get a camera in
this meeting like the stuff we're
talking about is ridiculous but so he
all heavies have a weak point and for
him it's his mouth so when if you could
get a rocket or a grenade or a sticky
bomb in his mouth you'll instantly
stagger him
your guy so that was baloney right there
know what he did
there you go
so he'll go yeah he'll he'll go who and
and again like these aren't just for
show like we put this stuff in here and
and we're gonna make you their tune so
you kind of have to do this because the
Cacodemons this time around is really
really hard
so by landing what we call a skill-shot
on him
you can shortcut the AI and basically
increase your chances of success
considerably so you got to learn all the
weak points every time you meet an AI
we'll put an entry into the codex the
codex this time will function a little
bit more like a bestiary what we'll put
gaming tips with each AI entry so you
could read up on what their weak points
are and what gun maybe works better
against them like with the cases that
plasma rifle and the shield guys so it's
cool it's a thinking man's action game
in speed chest all right let's do
another cool one we could do a better
one
oh my how much stuff me
leave let me hurt him
[Applause]
this is endlessly fun whoa what's going
I mean you're getting you're seeing you
go do it obviously you know very very
good at the game and those you know
knows it well but you know you got this
sense in 2016 a little bit but it's true
even more so and doom eternal you really
you feel like your own fight
choreographer while you're playing
once you learn once you learn the demons
and and there's so many glory kills to
do you really can can have fun making
your fights not only fun but but look
just spectacular
so I blood punch em in the blood punch
the feedback on the blood punch is
amazing so like everything in Doom you
know it's it's it's all about gameplay
and first it's not about you know it has
to look cool but it has to have serve a
purpose in the game so the blood punch
will with the rune can provide you with
health so it's another way to get health
when you do a blood punch and eventually
you can expand the damage that you do
with a blood bunch to do kind of a blast
radius that'll kill everything around
you so if you equip the rune that gives
you health on a blood punch and you have
invested in it and it's it's super
powered you could basically this time
around you want to farm the zombies so
we're gonna give you packs a zombies and
if you're smart you'll burn a group of
them like you know and then blood punch
them and you could basically stack the
resources that you're getting from each
AI so you know because they're on fire
I'm getting ammo and because I hit them
with the blood punch and I'm now gaining
health and again it's it's kind of this
a thinking man's action game
other ads to get to yeah yep
every time you see a green crack that's
kind of like main path and then you'll
see those those kind of heavy stark
black cracks and and everything from
walls to to vent when you punch through
those it's like this like we thought
about a lot it's like in dead space you
know his name is Isaac right guy in dead
space yeah he you know he fixes things
he's an engineer right that was what was
cool about that I love that game
but in Doom when we started it was just
like he just breaks things you know he's
like this pissed-off 14 year old and and
who can relate you know yeah just like
so
most of our puzzles like we have punch
blocks for example which have giant
punch symbols on them and and we have
green cracks which mean so if there's a
punch symbol that means you can move it
if there's a green crack on something
you could break it and if there's a kind
of this crosshair that's a shootable
it's an activator it'll activate
something really simple kind of binary
we call like 8-bit puzzles you know but
they're smart I mean the way that the
way that we combine them throughout the
game they build and build and build and
and while the number of things you could
do with them is limited the way that we
implement them is really pretty clever
and all just to add variety to the
gameplay even even these the tentacles
had you know something that honestly one
of the criticisms of doom 2016 was you
know you kind of got to a point where
it's it was a little bit monotonous a
little bit repetitive and the puzzles
that Hugo's talking about you know
things like tentacles surprises slime
there's a lot of things in the game this
time around that'll it'll really again
challenge you engage you just change up
the gameplay enough from from moment to
moment that you don't feel like you're
just going arena hallway arena hallway
certainly the arenas and the hallways
are just as fun but but now in the those
hallways again you'll be farming for
resources because the
oh the hole hook to the game is take
what you need from the enemies so in a
typical hallway we know you just left an
arena in the shipping game we might fill
this with zombies and you've got plenty
of things to do do I want to extract
health from ill use a blood punch I want
to burn them maybe chainsaw few maybe
glory kill if you like you're always
thinking about what you need to do next
and he mentioned the sludge like for
example we've got a material in the
world that if you if you walk through it
some of the some of the surfaces or
hazardous some of them slow you down on
don't allow you to - and then we
introduced tentacles into those
situations start combining things in
ways that make for some really
interesting moments in the game I think
some of the most compelling moments in
the game are actually outside of the
arenas we worked really hard on that I
mean we heard you guys feedback oh this
is the doom guy acting like a
fourteen-year-old again he's like get
out of here big fall yeah just trust
this is what he does I mean again he
he's we talked about this in an O clip
in a Giant Bomb interview you know one
on one size a hero on one side we've got
like a John McClane diehard guy right
Bruce Willis which he there's a lot of
humanity there he's fine of course right
bring it also it's letting you know that
listen man we're making a comic book
videogames you know like this is not to
be taken seriously
we we have a we have a ridiculous
premise but with sincere execution so on
one side we have John McClane and he's
like you know diehard hero shows a lot
of humanity on the other side we have
like a The Terminator or Michael Myers
who show very little humanity but when
they do it's really compelling and those
two characters Michael Myers and the
Terminator they what makes them so
entertaining is their their
uncompromising and they take the
shortest path to everything it's
something that we would all aspire to do
right just walk in take what we need and
walk out and and that's why we it's like
a power fantasy watching The Terminator
when everybody for a long tells a moment
you know hold on I have the keycard pass
and it's going to go through this whole
process of hacking into this thing and
the terminators just walks through the
wall you know that that's what makes him
so entertaining that is doom guy I mean
I think doom guy is closer to Michael
Myers and The Terminator and then he
takes the shortest path to everything
he's uncompromising and is that great
line in in Braveheart we're
uncompromising people are easy to admire
so and that that is true of the Doom's
layer so him getting in that that ball
and launching himself across he's not
doing it he just wants to get there and
he his his brain is like that that's
gonna be fast if I use the candidate you
know this was built around that premise
yeah like we haven't shown all of it but
there's some other moments that are
right along those lines people it's a
little bit of fun too it's like oh well
there's ya you you could take this quest
or go talk to this NPC and the doom guys
like how about I just take the key card
off that nerdy sign that Jess yeah like
I see explodable barrels throughout the
history of doom we're not big enough so
added summon space yeah yeah so put them
yes exactly
so these little things and I didn't do
this right that - that's another moment
those things right there you know that
they make you think like when do you
want to hit that jump pad will make you
have to think about it everything is you
can time your double jumps with your
dashes to really extend them so if you
see something that looks pretty far you
can take a chance and actually yep see
how far you get so I want to wait till
that thing is done but since it's not
gonna be done I'll take the wall climb
feel the thing get out of here before it
goes off again so I'll tell you actually
we haven't even said it like if you
haven't played the demo or haven't watch
kind of our past presentations - is like
you have basically a double - you can
see it in the kind of bottom left there
above the armor recharge is pretty fast
when you're on the ground
GameChanger I mean like it you you it's
very difficult to go back and play doom
2016 after you played doom eternal as
much as we love that game we always
complain like what in the hell when we
think this with the Crouch dashes
replaced you crashed once in a tunnel it
was awesome and then when you're on the
wall you actually have to trigger it
with a button right so yeah you do it
were you confessional you could dash
into it
oh that headshot was awesome
those are our pressure units and they
put a lot of pressure on you let me tell
you the hell nights are no joke and what
again I love is that they get in your
face so much that they'll really make
you consider whether or not you want to
keep running around with that rocket
launcher like it's a shotgun you know
it's gonna get you killed
this is existed honestly this is a great
example right here in in doom 2016 this
would have been a hallway you know but
with with everything we've done from you
know wanting the worlds to be bigger and
the the amount of engagement in going
from arena Terina that we wanted to we
wanted to add the diversity this is this
is the kind of gameplay that you get a
little bit of a little bit of puzzle
solving some some you know awesome
traversal using your your - and these
are things that you don't you know you
don't just use that I mean - is a combat
tool but but obviously incorporated into
you know into the level design part of
the game as well it's been a big big
focus for the team that that level
design component we're super proud of
our auto map it's it's synced with the
demonic corruption meter in the upper
right hand corner now this is a demo so
it's even better now it's more sync but
we're gonna let you know like that
symbol right there that red the two
swords that is a combat encounter every
time you complete a comment encounter
you will work your way towards unlocking
combat points which is what the demonic
the pips on the demonic corruption meter
represent each one of those as a combat
point you use those to invest in your
mods to increase the power of your
weapons which as we said the AI are
tuned to for you to exploit their weak
points you have to do skill shots so
you're really going to want to invest in
your mods this time some of the
encounters our secret encounters they'll
be represented by coloured gore nests
some of and then some of them are what
we call slayer gates which I'll be
coming up on in a minute so you're kind
of like the exterminator and you got to
get rid of all the demons to get all the
points and we have some optional
encounters in there marked by Gore Ness
so if you don't really if it will reward
you again for exploring with these
little mini encounters that if you win
you'll earn additional combat points and
look at all those secrets so I didn't
want to find those secrets
there are tons
tons of secrets in this game and the
lore in particular that's another thing
that if you really want to know more
about the world and what's going on then
read the lore pages that you could pick
up throughout the level so I tried that
would have been so cool if I would need
to do that you would have been legendary
and I'm running at it but some of these
platforms like this is actually a pretty
small area so you know yeah I like that
yeah so really got to be smart you might
not want to bust out the rocket so I am
going to a farm oh that feels so good it
hits like this weird part of your brain
that just feels awesome like stuff like
that I don't know there's no purpose for
that whatsoever no but it has to be not
a blow [ __ ] up though it's a good
example of a 1-up that's a little hard
like just you gotta have yeah slight bit
of skill there using your dash and
mobility so to grab that one up and it's
something to master again like I I don't
think you're gonna any any traversal
mechanic or quite frankly anything in
any game that I could master within a
couple of minutes is really not that
good so you know dashing into walls and
wall climbs is challenging in the
beginning so you see how my weapon will
let me know by the color that I was out
of resources so it lets me know
immediately that I have to chainsaw so
at first wall climbing and dashing into
walls and monkey bars and things like
that will be challenging and then as you
keep playing you get better and better
at it and it gets easier and easier and
you feel like you've accomplished
something and then you're able to do
more in the game unlock more secrets
sorry the weapon wheel that's a perfect
example like so I'm good to go so why
does why is the weapon wheel colored why
do we have so much color it's not it's a
it's a functional decision not an
ecstatic aesthetic one each each pip
each of these is colored to the
coordinated with the ammo that you pick
up in the world so when I get purple
stuff coming out of guys I know that I'm
getting
plasma energy ammo this is rockets so
it's color coordinated with the Pecha
pickups in the world so you read it
immediately as Marty said yeah sure yeah
you're you're in a race car doo-doo-doo
moves 200 miles an hour if we are not
big and bold with our messaging you are
going to die as a result and you will
think we are bad game designers so when
it's red and I go to the weapon wheel it
lets me know immediately just like in a
car we actually discussed that like the
the speedometer on a car is designed in
such a way so you could read it super
super fast and when shits read on your
speedometer like on your dashboard you
know that's a bad thing or flashing it's
even worse so as soon as you go to the
weapon wheel and it's red you know hey
I'm out of ammo and you also know what
you do have ammo for way faster than you
didn't do in 2016 we're putting a lot of
pressure on you to manage your resources
aggressively the AI is coming at you
hard you got to take out the skillshots
we got to tell you this stuff really
fast and we're and we're taking a we're
taking a pretty heavy hand with it but
you know we've actually seen a lot of
comments online about people you know
kind of displeased with the colors of
the UI or how bold it is you know we're
as Hugo pointed out we're we're we are
we're giving you all the information
exactly how you know how we think you
need it but there's gonna be a lot of
customization in the in the UI as well
you'll be able to adjust the the color
the opacity even turn on and off some of
the elements to your liking so this is
all again very much in development even
it's even been iterated on quite a bit
since since this as far as what the
default will be but but have no fear
you'll you'll you'll have lots of
options
oh you're just in the options menu to
customize your HUD and as you said
that's even so this is old for us yeah
many months yeah I mean we first
performance at the HUD the HUD if you
saw some of the footage of recently you
see that it's you know it's we're in
development so it's a little bit more
subdued a little bit more polished and
as Marty said but not a whole set not a
wholesale change by any stretch I mean
the the fundamental design principle
there is you need the information and if
you've played the game actually it's
it's interesting to talk to people who
have played the game
and and then you talk about like nobody
who plays the game talks about the hut
because it gives you the information
that you need as loud as you need it
asking people what they thought I mean a
lot of people are saying it's incredibly
helpful like you feel like you have that
arena like you would miss every
opportunity to you know you would you
wouldn't get into a Ferrari and say turn
off your life yeah you know I mean you
and look at the tachometer and be like
it's the orange is it's just put again
we're entering will give you the
controls just like we did last time to
make adjustments to it and again that
that extents everything I was talking
about earlier
how bright the the pickups are how
bright that that health pack is when you
go into an arena right now it's amazing
when you're playing the game
particularly on you know some of the
some of the more challenging arenas as
you get deeper into the thing the you
you you you pick out those things as
soon as you get into the arena you like
okay there's a health pack over there
there's three Rockets over there
Hugo talked about it yesterday in the
panel how how like how those things have
changed and you don't just mindlessly
pick them up anymore you're really
thinking through that process it yeah
it's super engaging cuz you're like okay
I'm okay on Rockets I I want to leave
those there I see that health pack I
know right where it is
when I get in trouble I'm gonna I'm
gonna scoot around there and and pick
that up
it's it really is like every I would say
as a fundamental rule everything is more
meaningful and do me geranyl and and you
really think about things this is I was
art there was our goal we wanted
everything to count more for you the
player so that way the whole the whole
game has more meaning so that is a
slayer gate key and in a secret and
that's the two pips on the top of the
demonic corruption meter relate to the
slayer gate and this is the slayer gate
some dimensional rift from another world
oh my goodness and there's a giant
there's a giant thing in there that is
not functioning and if I hit R I'll
break the game so
we will we will move on what spoilers
you know don't get the experiences and
in but it's dope and and that will
unlock like a super challenging arena
that you can go back to if you need to
because you're probably gonna get your
butt kicked if you haven't invested in
your mods and you're gonna get oh I
can't it's actually turn it off for the
demo yeah it doesn't work sorry I'm
sorry Howard you teased it too much I
know with the hut with the gun and stuff
the position of the gun I don't think
that's on here right now definitely not
but we will do that that delay of me
think we tweet that was waiting for
music I don't want to get in trouble
Marty and be like can't be announced
Annette what's fun is some of those it
can't it just makes you think some of
those tentacle they're they're dormant
so yeah you kind of walk through and
you're never quite sure just it's it's
fun it actually not all of them have
tentacles
you're not just racing down the hallway
you're really thinking your way through
and and they're just like demons like if
you it's it's pretty great if you come
across one of those and you're low on
ammo you can chainsaw them just like a
demon and and get and get resources or
burn them so I saw that there was a
question mark up there earlier and then
you got to look for the black cracks you
know they're pretty pretty subtle and
they will lead me to more secrets and
then I will burn and grenade and get the
feedback of all that green [ __ ] coming
into me it is awesome
we got some got some awesome secret
items collectibles huh like just a whole
revamped system for for all of that we
know how much you guys love the little
doom guy collectibles and I think you'll
you'll really really really like kinda
what we're doing from that perspective
this time around we mark secrets well
this is just another example of doom guy
just he's being efficient this is the
Terminator walking through the wall he's
uncompromising he's just how do I get to
the core of Mars as fast as possible
everybody's oh he takes an escape pod
yeah to the core of Mars everybody's
always trying to keep up with the Slayer
which is cool what the [ __ ] I'll do like
my own little master pancake thing of a
game I think we'll probably tint the
visor a little bit more so his face is
slightly more we've always seen the doom
guy's face from the original game so
certainly I we enjoy the fact that our
hero is someone who does have a face and
just to remind you this is the same
level like and only three little parts
of it so like this this levels big you
you have gone from a base on Phobos to
to BFG 10,000 to space and now to the
core of Mars that is like hell so it's
so you're in for some pretty epic
experiences yeah
so in places like these in the in the in
the in the game these are kind of the
moments where we test to see have you
have you mastered the experience do you
do you know the doom dance you know how
good are you at doom with you chains on
and you're burning in your weapon
switching and your weak points and your
skill shots and so arenas like this
you're gonna die a lot and we don't mind
killing you that's how we teach the
player and every time you die in a
well-balanced game every time you die
you know why you died and you think you
could do better in a poorly balanced
game you feel like it's the game that
screwed you and there was nothing else
you could do so whenever you die in Doom
there's probably something you did wrong
and you'll feel it and and that'll
encourage you to go back and try again
and do better that's true of
single-player and definitely true in
battle mode and so that's where the 1ups
helped out a lot too because we know
we're gonna kill you yeah you're good
yeah see that I'm out of ammo I ain't
playing good give me that stuff and the
Barrens of pressure unit and while in a
one-on-one situation the Baron might not
be too challenging because you're faster
than him what he does is he creates
openings for other demons to take
advantage of you looking the other way
while you're focusing on the Baron that
is the greatest the super shotgun with
the meathook mod I if you played you
probably got and when you get when you
really get good with it it is a it is a
life-changing experience honestly cuz
it's just it's so you know I talked
about the fight choreography type thing
I mean to be able to sling yourself off
of a demon sometimes you just use it to
get up close and and getting close for a
kill sometimes you can use it if you if
you pull yourself and right before you
get to the demon you didn't jump and
then use your double dash you can
actually sling yourself off of a demon
to get up to a higher elevation or to
swing around him you actually saw it
yesterday in some of the doom Hunter
videos he would pull himself to the doom
hunter flip over the doom hunter and
then get around behind him you can do
that really really effectively with the
pinkies you know you have to shoot them
in the butt to kill them a lot about
one-up doing that yeah exactly yeah you
can you can really do some fun stuff
it's hard yeah it's a little harder off
the well no I was gonna try to actually
get the 1up to get said that and I'm
definitely trying to look cool right now
and I'm not doing a good job so this guy
super pressure unit he's like super hell
night that guy's gonna kill you a bunch
oh and I'm using the rocket launcher Oh
like an idiot and that's what we want we
don't want you spamming the rocket lunch
we want you to respect the rocket
launcher you know a powerful weapon that
needs to be a t-shirt respect the rocket
launch you got it yeah but uh because if
I'm just running around like this and
you know using it like it's a machine
gun I mean that that's not a very well
balanced weapon the machine gun has its
place do that this scope is so awesome
for skill shots I mean you could just
like the dude like man when you get good
at the game like right now at the office
you know cuz we've got some more
balancing stuff going on tuning with the
weapons I mean you could just like
headshot dudes right kind of a quick
scope situation it just feels awesome
and taking out the Iraq neutrons gun
mid-fight you know just feels amazing
it's important they're actually really
fast they go they're on the breeze ask
around and I mean if you if you didn't
they're tuned to force you to want to
take out there there
points and if you don't you're gonna get
killed
so the Prowler that was a really great
example I literally took my hand off the
the joystick there's the one up right
there yeah he died you come I mean
you're literally you just stay in the
action screen goes gray you're a moment
of invulnerability to kind of find your
find your footing in you're right back
in the action
the so everything about the game is is
too we don't want you to stop moving got
to keep moving there's there's kind of a
Tony Hawk pro skater vibe that's going
on that feels awesome
that game was awesome and we're talking
gold and I were talking Tony we're
talking about some good games man okay
and if I stand still
let's see if this let's see how long
this takes okay that didn't take long at
all so there you go
don't don't stop moving and the Prowler
really really proud of every AI is a
chess piece and it's got weaknesses and
it's got strengths the Prowler can
teleport to wherever you are so for the
player who's like I got an idea I just
bought doom and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna hang out in this little cave and
like you know just game the AI or like
hi the Prowler will teleport I'm gonna
die will teleport right to your location
and rip you to shreds because his
teleporter usually spawns like right
behind the player so he his job every
job every AI has a job to get the player
to play the game correctly and his job
is to prevent you from sitting still and
he does it extremely well so he is
certainly an AI that you want to
prioritize on the battlefield where
these 1ups work out real nice because I
don't have even do a checkpoint so the
the Gauss
Maude is very effective against flying
demons it will usually one-shot them and
I am out of shotgun so we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna chainsaw this guy cuz
I've had enough to him so I got to do
this one Gloria kill to him that's
insane
let's see if I could do it alright come
on
alright dude you're killing me right now
oh that the it's actually interesting
you see the if you play 2016 you know
the hell night watch it sit still and
die thank you
the hell night and the the guy with the
orange blade to the dreadknight they the
Internet people
huh I'm Chyna it's this one where you
Steven Seagal and me like break his arm
and stick his bone in his head it's
awesome
the enemies are really tuned to force
you to use the dash so you know when the
when the hell Knights attacking the
dread Knights attacking those jumps that
they do it's it's incredibly rewarding
and honestly necessary to be able to -
out of the way turn around and write it
they're landing you kind of land a good
double-barrel super shotgun shot or if
you get far enough away a rocket
launcher see that skill shot that was
awesome that was awesome
it makes it easier to get behind enemies
like the pinkie - yeah absolutely right
at you all right come on oh I want to do
your thing
we're gonna finish him off a little nice
because he his his area of denial dude
that you cannot you cannot get close to
the mang cubist it's one of my favorite
things
you know last game you could pretty much
run up to a lot of guys and just kind of
double-barrel them in the face and which
was cool I mean it you know wheel of
doom eternal but doing 2016 but like I
love that's the some of the AI again the
carcass will make you think about how
you're using the rocket launcher the
mang cubist will make you reconsider
your your attacks with with a double
barrel so the key to him you got to take
out his guns because he's like insane
with these things nice all of the
projectiles in the game everything is
tuned to both in battle mode and in
single-player to the speed of the player
so this this basically broke the game so
we put this in - right and then all of a
sudden with with the chess pieces tuned
to the speed so casually the the chess
pieces tuned to the speed of the player
of 2016 once we added - we saw like holy
cow the game no one can touch me which
is fun for about 10 minutes and then you
just you know you just get bored because
you're not challenged or pushed at all
so you know the racecar got faster the
race the racetrack had to get a little
bit more complicated so we tuned all the
AI behaviors attacks the speed of their
projectiles the speed of their melee
strikes to account for your ability to
get in and get out really fast
so everybody's real aggressive so if you
ain't - and tactically to get in get out
if you think you're just gonna walk up
to somebody and go bang like you're
getting rekt so you know you got to come
in you know get out get out of the way
dodge there the the carcass has got a
gnarly melee swipe it's it's awesome
look at that environment yeah I need to
pop and look at this our RF you should
probably kill the guy who's bugging out
over there
yes let's split zoom in on a [ __ ]
yacht I am going to get this farm kill
on this guy see see what he does he's
tough all right sorry
and you to the HAR is a great fodder
weapon for glory chills you know glory
killing always guarantees you more
health than a normal kilt
so you're gonna want to use that
tactically
that was not
[Applause]
at one last one yay because yeah look at
us of the new glory kills I mean if that
you have a favorite of the new glory
filled oh well the one I'm trying to do
the way yeah I wasn't trying to rub salt
in the wound you've seen it in the
trailer yeah you know he breaks his arm
and then shoves his arm bone I mean that
looks crazy yeah and look we're at the
core of Mars yeah you started you
started way up there so he went on from
us from the moon to outer space and then
to the core but what created this giant
hole in Mars Marty you'll find out
that's what I you did the doom Slayer
does there was a big giant gun
compromising there was a big giant BFG
and then there's this hole and he was
people always ask what that was shooting
at yes we don't know I guess and where's
this going
yes let's find out November
well I know we don't have a ton of time
but there are a ton of questions you
mind if we rattle off a few we can do
lightning round
okay let's do it you ready yeah you have
nowhere to go so first of all we get
this question all the time obviously if
you watch the trailers you hear the
music and the music is a big part of
doom so doom eternal make Gordon's back
right we're gonna have great sounds
absolutely yeah yeah so that's a
question from I should say most in games
so shout out to you from spreading if
I'm like butchering any Slayers rod
names greedy sir do you want to talk
about how much time has passed between
sort of the ending of 2016 and eternal
or is that a little bit you know enough
for the [ __ ] to hit the fan on earth I
guess so yeah definitely it's a
continuation of that story and as you
can see Earth has fallen on hard times
so it's it's it's a little bit a little
ways after doom 2016 cool yeah this is a
Ben Zakai is heaven with us or against
us I think the proper question is are
you with or against heaven yeah alright
damn gonna be gay obviously we can see
his biceps now so every wants to know
how's he gonna strength the doom Slayer
that's a question from I mean isn't this
working
he's ripping and tearing demons apart
all the time that's his workout yeah
pretty much
I don't know that it's funny we had a
discussion about that does he lift I'm
like I don't he's not like a bro right
you know I don't think he drinks protein
so yeah I think if anything it's more
what do they call that exercise where
it's more like body weight and not not
so much with weights yeah something like
that calisthenics using the limbs of
demons or something you do thank you
I mean yeah maybe I guess we eat you'll
learn a lot about him yeah you will
learn oh you'll learn more about him
then then we'll actually answer that
question yeah yeah
he'll see kind of like where he hangs
out again if you care you'll see how he
spends his free time and and you'll
you'll learn a lot about him through the
game if you if you look for it and pay
attention it's pretty cool
the doom eternal trailer whose narrating
that that trailer every trailer we got a
lot of questions about that you know
wasn't clear some people thought it was
Samuel er this was all right that's a
good Easter egg that is the voice from
the beginning of doom 2016 the voice
that says they are raged brutal
relentless without mercy be you will be
worse that's him and he plays a part in
the doom universe okay this question was
asked and I know you touched on it a
little bit but in terms of the
collectibles that you'll find this is
from DB mall 27 anything you want to
hint about about just more collectibles
in the game yeah I mean there's there's
more yeah there's more collectibles some
more types of collectibles and and and I
mean III think this is super cool so I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it we basically
instead of just doomed doomed eyedolls
we've got all of the demons so yeah
they're freaking unbelievable little toy
vertol toy versions of all of every
character in the game that are like the
greatest thing ever it is there so
you're gonna love it and and you're
gonna want to not only collect them all
in the game you're gonna want to buy
them all think I already want them yeah
Ricky I keep sending them to the to the
merchandising guy Gary we're just like
you guys when we see the final model
we're like take my money yeah exactly
like where where can i buy this you got
room for one more yeah yeah yeah let's
do it
do you have one or you know you this is
a question man you saw a few times based
on the trailer from e3 the new
cyberdemon is that psilocybin demon
that's from mr. narwhals
worse cyberdemons are like a class of
demons so they could be because there's
I think the doom 3 cyberdemon obviously
is a cyberdemon the doom 2016 ones a
cyberdemon the doom from 1993 in you
know doom 64 is like each each doom game
has a cyberdemon and
so it's just a class of cyberdemon and
this is the latest iteration on the
almost like a species you know so this
is the latest cyberdemon yes he's
actually called the tyrant in this game
inspired by the classic design oh yeah
absolutely
oh yeah as is everything you know yeah a
lot of the designs the man Kubis you
know have that doom to look so very cool
the whole game everything I'll do is is
really really tapping into those
original games sweet that's how good
they were
yeah well thank you guys very much
obviously thank you all for coming out
today thank you
keep your honorable pulse to Hugo I'm
Artie for coming up that till the turtle
comes out November 22nd thanks for
watching and we'll see you thank you
guys thanks guys thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]